and finally today
that footage that Tucker Carlson got his
hands on 44 000 hours of footage from
January 6th security cameras all over
Congress given to him by Kevin McCarthy
a coalition of news organizations are
now suing the federal government to get
their hands on that very same footage
that has been handed over to Tucker
Carlson
those organizations include Advanced
Publications the Associated Press CNN
CBS the ew Scripps company Gannett the
New York Times Politico and propublica
and basically what they've done is
they've sued the federal government
well not necessarily sued the federal
government I that man may be the wrong
word they filed a motion in federal
court saying that we have jumped through
all the Hoops we have filled out all the
paperwork the Freedom of Information Act
requests asking the FBI the doj to turn
over this same footage which is
technically already publicly available
via Tucker Carlson so it's not like it's
hidden it's not like it's top secret or
classified
we want this information so the the news
organizations are asking the court to
compel the government to turn it over to
them
I hope this lawsuit works I think it
needs to work for the good of the
country because Tucker Carlson got that
footage and did exactly what everybody
predicted he was going to do
he showed weird camera angles that just
showed people walking down a hallway and
then he was like see they're not violent
it's just like tourists on a trip
they're learning it's a field trip
and of course he omitted all of the part
where they're breaking Windows climbing
up walls smashing vases stealing stuff
jumping over chairs with a bundle of zip
ties on their belt yeah all the really
important things Tucker Carlson said
yeah we don't need to talk about that
he's whitewashing the events of that day
to make Republicans look better
these news organizations want that same
footage so that they can show what
really happened
you can't just show a piece of the
puzzle and say oh yes clearly that is a
basket of puppies
you have to put the whole puzzle
together every single piece of it and
another thing
that I think Tucker Carlson didn't take
into consideration is that those people
that he's shown just walking around that
building being peaceful
their very presence in that building
is what's a crime because even if they
were just walking around
they were still trespassing on federal
property and interrupting an official
government proceeding
so those videos Tucker showed could
actually lead to more prosecutions and
arrests in the future
listen that's all the time we have for
today I've got an exceptionally fun
bonus show coming up thank you David
thank you team for letting me fill in uh
for these last two days I am fair and
cousins you can find me on YouTube at
youtube.com the ring of fire youtube.com
fairandbalanced Twitter Facebook
Instagram Tick Tock at farrenbalanced
thank you so much and stay tuned for the
bonus show